so I'm just sipping on my cup of green
tea to start my day I always need to
have my green tea first thing in the
morning so it's going to be another
really busy weekend and I know that I
won't have time to work out later on in
the day so before I do anything it is
really important that I fit in my me
time and do a quick workout to start of
the weekend strong I'm just about to
head out I'm going to meet the ladies
from Cubs gym I'm currently running a
four-week healthy living workshop with
them so for the past two weeks I taught
them how to write food journal workout
journal the basic of understanding a
healthy meal plan how to do simple home
exercises and so for week three we want
to go food shopping
the ladies are really looking forward to
this I am as well I'll be teaching them
how to read ingredients list how to
understand the basic nutritional values
and also how to make healthy food
choices when it comes to doing your
weekly grocery shopping so I'm just
about to meet the ladies and before I
leave home there are certain things that
I must have with me the most important
is my movement watch I'm always on the
move and as much as I can I don't like
being late so wearing a watch really
helps me to stay on top and stay on
track for the entire day I really like
the movement watch because it's so
simple yet it's very stylish and it's
really well built so it's great for my
active lifestyle or even when I'm just
in my casual we're conducting a workshop
so don't forget to check out the link in
my description box for more designs you
will love it and I've lost my sunglasses
because it's always hot and sunny in
Malaysia I always have this on and I
also like to fill up my flask with hot
green tea to sleep on the entire day not
forgetting my small snack container it's
just a simple mix of nuts seeds and
dried fruits for me to snack on just in
case I need a quick energy boost
right I've got it it's more to have 12
and hopefully all the ladies will be
there on time ready and excited to do
their food shopping right so I'm at the
supermarket right now and I'm just with
the curves ladies and we'll be doing our
food shopping
okay ladies do you want to say hi yeah
lovely group of ladies before that let's
just go through the boring part very
important bit I've given the ladies a
grocery list each and also some tips and
notes on healthy food shopping I
actually don't need all this food but
chances are when they are already in
your fridge or food cupboard you with
them there you go you even so we're just
going through the different sections in
the supermarket to look at some of their
favorite products how to read
nutritional labels ingredients list how
to compare the products and make better
choices and also how not to be fooled by
the health claims such as low fat no
sugar no cholesterol organic 100%
natural and more so most of the ladies
are mothers and I feel that it is
extremely important for them to learn
how to make healthier and smarter
choices and lead their family to eat
better
so I just got back and not too long ago
it's about half five right now and I
want to film a quick workout video for
you guys I can run out of ideas as well
I have been having crazy days crazy
weeks and sometimes I don't even have
the time to fit a solid workout session
in but before the end of my day I will
always make sure to do a quick workout
just to keep my body moving to feel
better to unwind and also for me to
sleep better and so I thought you know
what let me share with you my quick
eight-minute lazy couch potato workout
which you can do from the comfort of
your own home while watching TV while
waiting for the commercial break
basically I want you to just get moving
on a daily basis no matter how short it
is okay so yeah I just have to share
this clip with you on what happened
during my filming if you find this
workout to be helpful so go find the
workout on my channel get it done before
the end of the day I'm going to grab a
quick dinner have an early night because
I'm running a workout event with adidas
tomorrow Wow selamat pagi
is how we would say it in Malaysia so
I've been up since 7:00 a.m. I've had my
quiet time I find it really important
for me to have a strong and productive
day ahead as you can see I'm already I'm
really excited
full of energy because I will be
conducting a 45 minute high-intensity
workout session with the adidas ladies
so I'm expecting about 20 to 25 ladies
who have signed up to show up it's a
Sunday morning it's really early in the
morning but instead of lying in bed we
want to sweat it out really push and
motivate each other to give our best so
if you're watching this make sure to
make it a sweaty Sunday
just on my way to traveling here right
now it's bright and sunny today and you
know what I actually really enjoy
driving on a Sunday morning because the
road is clear there isn't any traffic
and I can just get to my destination on
time without getting stuck in the
terrible Jam you know what you'll be so
amazing if I can just conduct my workout
session with all of you guys that would
be literally a dream come true
so yeah hopefully one day I'm here in
the adidas store they literally moved
all the clothes racks and cut up the
entire space for us to do our workout
it's crazy I never thought that I'll be
running a workout event in an Adidas
store in a shopping center so the ladies
are just registering and collecting
their goody bags and of course picture
time I really love meeting each and
every one of you in person so if you
ever run into me do you say hi the
energy in this room is crazy it's just
so inspiring to be with all these ladies
here sweating and motivating each other
on a Sunday morning
okay good
we follow the way
the above
like we are
great things ahead let's go
every amazing workout session needs to
end with a big sweaty hug to spread the
positive vibe I'm just back at home
right now I'm going to reply some emails
and also get on with my video editing I
am so grateful for all the opportunities
that have come my way since I uploaded
my first video on YouTube three years
ago this is a big part of my finished
career and it is the platform for me to
reach out to all of you across the world
it has been a long weekend I will need
to find some time off for myself soon
but you know what I am not complaining I
have to be honest I am tired but I feel
really fulfilled and blessed I made the
conscious decision that when I wake up
every day I want to continue to learn
live my best life and to live my life's
purpose so I don't just want to wake up
go to work and wait for the day to end
or wait for the weekend to come but
instead I want to be able to connect
with you guys whether it's through my
youtube videos whether it's through
events or workouts and know that I'm
able to add a little bit of value in
other people's life knowing that makes
me feel really fulfilled really happy
and dip down I know that that's what I'm
supposed to do so this is a little bit
of insight on what I do I hope you enjoy
this video I hope it will inspire you to
live your best life and always remember
to give your best in everything that you
do continue to learn continue to grow
yourself just be the positive energy
that other people want to be around and
be the bright light that continue to
shine okay guys don't forget that and
obviously remember to give time back to
yourself as well all the best
you